there have been many proclaimed game
changers in the medical fight back
against coronavirus this is the latest
the us-made drug molnupiravir was
initially intended to treat the flu it
works by inserting errors into the
genetic code of the virus limiting its
ability to multiply in the body
in practical terms it's the first covet
medicine that can be taken in pill form
at home to help the most vulnerable
avoid severe disease and last month the
uk became the first country to approve
its use i'm a research nurse working on
a new national kobit 19 study calling
you to see if you'd be interested in
taking part researchers at the
university of oxford are testing it in
more than 10 000 volunteers who've
recently contracted covert 19 like 51
year old glynn talling i had to take i
think four in one go
twice a day so with a 12-hour gap
over a period of five days
and nothing special about the medication
literally just normal capsules that you
take with water so all very
straightforward i had no side effects
there are already questions over the
effectiveness of molnupiravir after
clinical trial results led the
manufacturers to reduce the overall
efficacy of the drug from fifty percent
to thirty percent if you look at the
studies generally thirty percent is
actually a very very high level in terms
of the benefits that we see on a
large-scale study
and and that's what we want to replicate
here as well
while nu pirivia is one of several new
home treatments for covid to be tested
in what's being called the panoramic
study they're likely to include the fisa
produced paxlovid it's a combination
therapy based on old hiv treatments that
pfizer claims is up to 90 percent
effective in preventing hospitalizations
in high risk patients
with half a million courses already on
order here in the uk the focus for now
is firmly on molnupiravir if you catch
kovid19 early on and you treat it early
on you might then not be able to develop
any severe symptoms and this means
reduction in
hospital admissions and possibly taking
off some of the pressure on the nhs so
quite an important study i think molnu
pirivia and drugs like it could prove
valuable additions to a fast-growing
medical arsenal jonah al jazeera london